[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unique dass
bis zum ende des vierten jahrhundert
hatten sie von alles orte vorwiegend nur
logische werke und nicht einmal alle
logische werke und von platon hatten sie
nur ein teil von einem dialog nämlich
timaeus also die zugang zu antike
philosophie war es dann sehr beschränkt
ab ende des zwölften jahrhunderts wird
es ganz anders und ab so zweite drittel
des seit 30 jahren ist die situation
sogar sehr gut hinsichtlich alles dort
ließ die übersetzungen von wilhelm von
werke aus dem ring aus den reglern
griechischen fassungen jetzt aus den
arabischen meer trägt die ideen von zb
thomas von aquin ein kollege von und
dann später das was ich denke und wie
gesagt das ist ein grund warum ich mich
auf diese späte phase der beteiligten
sowie kurs enthalten werde
[Musik]
ich würde sagen dass für unser thema der
wichtigste denke nichts thomas von aquin
ist sondern albertus magnus sein lehrer
und amerikanischer philosoph theologe
der immer wieder unterwegs war innerhalb
europas er war in verschiedenen städten
köln behauptet eine sehr starke
beziehung verzerrtes mangel zu haben vor
der uni in köln steht sogar eine statue
von ihm aber na ja zu uns war er auch
längere zeit in regensburg regensburg es
zwar eine stadt wo er tätig war und er
ist für uns besonders wichtig weil er
wirklich der war eigentlich der erste
philosoph des mittelalters der
die das ziel hatte die sämtliche
europäische werke zu lesen verstehen und
zu kommentieren sogar einschließlich die
so logische werke was das keine andere
zahl für das offene gemacht haben
sie solle logische werke waren vor gegen
würden vorwiegend mitgelesen sogar von
personen die dazu zugang hatten zb in st
diese werke natürlich immer existiert
haben sonst würden wir sie nicht haben
weil jemand das was im gesamt verloren
geht ist für uns auch verloren mit ist
ein saft griechisch weil wir die
griechische überlieferung nur durch die
zahntechnische situation haben wie
vorhergesagt habe das heißt sie sollten
solche werke waren immer präsent in der
in der byzantinischen platz hat man hier
beißt ist ein dänisches wirklich
konstantinopel das war der der ort wo
alle handschriften vorhanden worden
aber es dauert bis michael von offices
dass wir kommentare zu dieser haben
das heißt durch die ganze spätantike und
durch die erste hälfte der geschichte
der italienischen fluss wie haben wir
eigentlich keine auseinandersetzung mit
den so logischen werken mindestens keine
kommentare das heißt nicht dass sie
gänzlich ungelesen geblieben sind aber
die waren wirklich keine beliebte werke
und das gilt auch für die lateinische
welt die wir gesehen haben war waren war
die theologie in der islamischen welt
sie wichtig solche designer seine eigene
fassung einer solo geschrieben in
reaktion auf die erste technologie und
es gibt so serbische werke von
er verwies auch wahrscheinlich unter
anderem weil sie durch die arabische
sation gesehen haben das so logisch
ökologische philosophie doch interessant
ist haben die lateinische übersetzer
dass auch übersetzt und albertus magnus
hat das kommentiert hat auch über
pflanzen geschrieben war wirklich sehr
sehr hatte wirklich sehr viel interesse
eine empirische wissenschaft npd
schaeffler sowie die tatsache dass er so
viel um gereist ist ist damit nicht
verbunden da weil er als dominikanische
manche ist ja immer zu fuß
überall hingegangen und er war praktisch
so sagen immer in der natur barfuß und
hat auf dem weg anscheinend sehr viele
beobachtungen gemacht die in seine
kommentare rhein fließen und erzählt
sogar dass er zum beispiel ein bienen
nester beobachtet hat dadurch dass er
sich von einer klippe runter steigen
gelassen hat um das nähe zu beobachten
als er war wirklich abenteuerlichen
hatte sehr viel interesse und war sehr
neugierig in dieser was sagen nicht
typisch ist für latein mittelalter es
ist wirklich ein außenseiter in dieser
hinsicht aber wie gesagt ist eigentlich
der einzige der dazu was sagen da ist
was zu sagen hat
auch bei thomas von aquin wilhelm von
ökonomie des chores johannes boliden all
diese klassiker erwähnen tiere
mindestens anpassen
wieso machen sie das aus zwei gründen
vorwiegend oder mindestens zwei gründen
erstens einfach um die aristotelische
psychologische theorie zu erklären und
auszubauen detaillierter zu gesprächen
und auf probleme innerhalb dieser
psychologischen theorie
zu erwähnen und lösen erstens das und
zweitens weil sie sich für diese grenze
zwischen tier und mensch interessiert
haben
das hat eine philosophische bedeutung
hat aber auch theologische bedeutung
denken wir zum beispiel daran dass in
der christlichen glaube menschen ein
nachleben haben und dann wieder
aufstehen werden also wieder neue körper
am ende der zeit bekommen werden das
gilt für tiere nicht und man könnte sich
fragen warum wieso ist das der fall dass
menschen tot durch leben können und wir
auch haben sie gedanken dass darüber
gedacht wieso menschen moralisch handeln
können und ihre nichts wieso sind tiere
nicht fähig moralische moralisch
bedeutende handlungen zu unternehmen
sie können zb andere tiere angreifen und
bringen und wir würden würden sie sagen
dass das schlecht ist
auch wenn das andere tier unschädlich
ist wieso also die grenze der der moral
der des moralischen bereichs wasser
sowie sowohl wie für theologie wichtig
ist ist irgendwie mit dieser mit dieser
tier mensch grenze identisch und es
interessantes zu fragen warum
im großen ganzen aber haben die schola
sticker dass wir das mag ein bisschen
enttäuschend klängen aber hoffentlich
werden sie sehen dass das ist nicht so
schlimm ist aber das erste was ich sagen
würde jetzt die 30 haben grundsätzlich
nichts neues
zu diesen fragen zu sagen im großen und
ganzen also ist sie bleiben innerhalb
der allosterischen wellen theorie und
stellen sie nicht so stark in frage wie
zum beispiel profibus das in
der im spät in der nacht in der
spätantike tut es gibt keine soweit ich
weiß gibt es keine klassische denker bis
ende des 14 jahrhunderts die zum
beispiel sagen wollen dass tiere genauso
sprechen können wie menschen die profis
behauptet hat hole das tier dem
moralisch handeln können oder sogar dass
wir das ist sehr moralisch sehr wichtig
ist dass wir tiere gut behandeln wie wir
in der islamischen welt sehen also im
allgemeinen würde ich sagen würde ich
sagen und vielleicht kenne ich einfach
die texte nicht gut genug aber so weit
wie ich gesehen habe
stellen die frage ist ein klassiker
einfach die aristotelische zellen und
tier theorie weniger in frage
als später antike denker und sogar als
islamisches denken und haben sind
weniger innovativ in dieser hinsicht und
vielleicht denken sie jetzt okay jetzt
gehe ich dann kommen nächste woche für
renaissance zurück aber es gibt
sozusagen eine ausgleichende bemerkungen
die ich so ausgelastet machen würde
nämlich dass sie sehr sehr tief und
detailliert diese theorie überlegen die
die am weitesten entwickelte version der
esoterischen tierlehrer die jemals
existiert hat war nicht bei ja dass dort
wie s und auch nicht in der spätantike
und wahrscheinlich auch mit dem
islamischen welt sondern auch nicht bei
michel von office sondern in der schweiz
plastik also hier haben wir sozusagen
der gipfel und die höchste phase die
höchste phase der entwicklung der
ästhetischen theorie die jetzt die uns
jetzt seit 1000 jahren verfolgt hat und
die führen irgendwie immer noch im
hintergrund ist wenn wir an unsere
intuition
über tiere denken also es ist sehr
wichtig aber nichts weiß nicht so sehr
von alles ds ab wie wir manchmal gesehen
haben
okay ich habe sie geschrieben habe
aristotelische bloße die durch paris ist
immer noch aktueller stand im 13 und 14
jahrhundert also nur als erinnerung was
heißt das das heißt dass die seele als
ein bündel ein bündel der von
fähigkeiten verstanden wird und die
fähigkeiten waren unter 33 gruppen
nämlich vegetative fähigkeiten zb gerne
herum und fortpflanzung dann die
sogenannte tier seele oder wahrnehmungen
zähle aber sagen wird die seele und
damit haben wir mit bewegung zu tun
beziehungsweise selbst bewegung und
wahrnehmung auch zum beispiel emotionen
und wie wir bei designer gesehen haben
vorstellungen und die andere so genannte
internen also gedächtnis es thematisch
oder machen dass sie es sich anders
das schafft die serie sich an das schaf
das empfinden kann dass der wolf ihm
feindlich ist ja und das macht man mit
dieser mit dieser fakultät ist
thematisch
dass die lateinische übersetzung von dem
arabischen wort und ich werde heute
relativ viel zu dieser fähigkeit noch
mal sagen müssen dann ganz oben haben
wir natürlich die 15
und das ist menschen eigen
also nur nur und unter den körperlichen
lesen haben nur menschen vernunft engel
und gott haben kann natürlich auch
denken und engel sind wirklich sagen wer
sie besitzen wo der intellekt besitzen
wir ihnen sagen das wort intellektuelles
oder internet verwendet das fällt bei
nichtmenschlichen tieren ist bei
menschen und hängen und gott vorhanden
wenn wir gott ist natürlich schwierig
also vielleicht muss man sagen gottes zu
erhaben als 50 oder als intellekt
verschiedenen zu werden habe er kann
mindestens denken und wissen damit wie
man oft in der geschichte der frist lief
am wenigsten mittelalter bemerkt ist der
mensch irgendwie der mittelpunkt aller
dinge hat sozusagen ein tier aspekt sein
tierisches aspekt und ein göttliches
aspekt oder ein aspekt was wir mit den
engeln teilen das sind ein göttliches 1
1 quasi göttliches intellekt in einem
tierkörper und das heißt dass dick und
damit haben wir ein problem wir heute
sein werden und dass es ist irgendwie
das problem dass wir immer wieder
gesehen haben in dieser ganzen vorlesung
folgen vorlesungsreihe gesehen haben
diese grenze zwischen hinzu der selben
tag und von und seele ist gleichzeitig
die grenze zwischen tier und mensch und
irgendwie eine grenze innerhalb der
menschlichen
zum beispiel haben wir bei den platanen
kann und bei marken islamischen den
philosophen gesehen dass die behauptung
gesehen dass die seele nachdem der
körper stirbt die zelle die übrigen
bleibt die die ballett ist nur dieser
vernunft seele und das könnte dazu
führen dass wir denken auch okay diese
unterdessen teilen haben gar nichts mit
mir zu tun das gehört nicht zu meiner
identität wenn ich das verlieren kann
mit meinen körper dann bin ich mit
diesen zellen unter dem center nicht
mehr identisch mit nicht mehr identisch
als ich mit meinem körper identisch
betten
es gibt aber mehrere gründe
diese annahme in frage ist einen vor
allem aus christlicher perspektive
erstens so fisch gesehen ist es ein
bisschen ungünstig wenn wir wenn wir
zugeben dass die seele keine einheit
bildet war das das klingt fast als ob
zwei oder sogar drei zellen haben müsste
also eine seele die stirbt die zelle
oder vielleicht sogar zwei stellen die
sterben meine tiere um eine franzen
seele und dann eine seele die über
überlebt ich meine wenn ich mein körper
stirbt das irgendwie falsch als
psychologischer perspektive
wir wollen dass die säle eine einheit
ist das ein problem
ein anderes problem ist natürlich dass
christen die auferstehung des körpers
aufrecht halten wollen und von daher
neigen sie dazu nichts sagen zu wollen
dass der körper so occident l ist für
für das ich wie man das manchmal in der
platonischen tradition sieht also die
wollen irgendwie sagen
selbst wenn ich als seele ohne körper
über überleben kann und weiter
existieren kann
da fragt irgendwas dann ist die frage
wieso
wer etwas mögliche antwort ich bin als
mensch auch tier also ich brauche meinen
körper damit ich ein perfekter mensch
bin nämlich damit meine auch tierische
tierisches aspekt zusammen
vollkommen ausüben und genießen kann zb
irgendwas wahrnehmen können um ein
vollständiger mensch zu sein und wenn
ich wenn ich das so sagen himmel
erreichen würde man herausfinden würde
dass ich nur eine filmszene bin dann
könnte ich sagen ja okay das ist zwar
toll also göttliches essenz zu
betrachten und so weiter mal spaß aber
ich möchte auch was sehen und musik
hören können werde werde das noch mit
werde das nicht mehr möglich
herrgott und dann sagt gott natürlich
das braucht ihr körper zurück sogar ein
perfekter körper besser als dieser
körper den sie jetzt vor ihnen sehen
wenn sie das sich vorstellen kann
sie wollen also sie haben gute gründe
theologisch und wieder so viele gründe
zu sagen dass diese grenze keine
spaltung innerhalb der menschlichen
natur ist
trotzdem wollen sie auch sagen dass
tiere vollständige zellen besitzen also
es nicht also ob tiere irgendwie
detektive menschen des 1 und sie sind
auch und noch grundlegender sie sind
auch beseelt gewesen
sie haben auch eine seele es gibt eine
interessante passagen bei roger bacon 1
englische viele server aus dem dritten
jahrhundert weiß nicht wie man roger
bacon auf deutsch sprechen wollen
wo und warum er von sascha kever
und er sagt dass die vielleicht nur die
gebildeten und philosophen verstehen
dass tiere das nichtmenschliche tiere
auch zählen haben weil die normale
menschen würden sagen es geht das als
seele ist richtig nur das ewige
unsterbliche denn was in der in denen in
den menschen innewohnt und er sagt nein
nein wenn man hat es gut mit der sich
gut mit einer sachliches auskennt da
sieht man dass pflanzen und tiere auch
seelen haben weiß er nicht mehr und
nicht weniger ist als dies all diese
fähigkeiten
das ist dessen fähigkeiten die durch den
körper ausgibt werden sind sind dabei
mit dem körper nicht identisch also die
diese grenze zwischen mensch und tier
ist weder eine grenze zwischen serie und
nicht selber noch eine grenze zwischen
zwei naturen verschiedenen naturen die
innerhalb eines menschen existieren
es gibt nur es gibt irgendwie eine
einheit in den mensch in der nasszelle
die das tier aspekt und das mensch
aspekt kombinieren und wir sagen
philosophen interessieren sich sehr für
diese für diese möglichkeit und wollen
das verstehen
nur als beispiel davon
thomas von aquin war dafür berüchtigt in
dem in dem zeitalter waldherr gelehrt
hat das mit nur der mensch sondern jede
substanz mehrere formen hat sogar viele
formen zb nehmen für mich als beispiel
die form des körpers weil ich ein körper
habe ich habe die form
ich habe dann eine pflanze ich habe auch
eine tier seele und dann habe ich die
vernunft seele und dann habe ich viele
aktien telefon
aber ich sogar meine substanz formen zb
körper und mensch sind zwei verschiedene
formen also er hat sich so ist so
konzipiert dass jede jede substanz ist
sozusagen schichtweise mehrere formen
aufeinandergestapelt besitzt und das
hält ihnen zu erklären dass wir all
diese diese fähigkeiten haben und dann
wollte er auch sagen dass bei der
substanz 1 substanz ist kommen sie alles
zusammen in einer einheit
viele andere so lästig dachten aber dass
das blödsinn ist bzw habe das einfach
nicht verstanden wie kann er das sagen
dass es einfach offensichtlich falsch
ein substanz eine form wie kann es nicht
eine substanz haben mit vieles
substanzielle formen und das ist ein
beispiel von einer übrigens unter
geschätzten tatsache nämlich dass thomas
für nächsten sehr weit weg war von
typischen mit salzen philosoph sogar in
space
jahrhundert zu sein er war wirklich ein
komischer vogel im rahmen der space 2 10
jahrhundert und hatte ideen die
philippinische waren es durchschnittlich
und einfach identitäten waren die fast
niemandem geteilt hat und das ist ein
beispiel und andere wie gesagt haben
andere versorgen das einfach nicht
akzeptieren wollen ein bisschen böse
nicht verstanden und es hat wirklich
gedauert jahrhunderte gedauert bis das
verrücken als zentraler figur der mit
leistung philosophie verstanden wird ich
glaube wenn man die antwort ist
klassiker und der
paris zu kurz nach dem tod von thomas
werner king gesagt es wird die 12 70
wenn man diesen so lars ricken gesagt
hätte übrigens in der zukunft werden
alle denken dass dieser thomas der
wichtigste für das oft sich dieser zeit
war hätten sie gesagt thomas der der
decke des abgefahren
das kann nicht sein aber mit der zeit
und durch einfluss seiner der
dominikaner nur der zunehmend als
zunehmend attraktiv genommen
und irgendwie hat sich jetzt erfolgreich
als der mitte alles so einen ruf
erworben was damals überhaupt nicht der
fall sein
auf jeden fall das ist nur ein beispiel
wie man das konzipieren konnte diese
vielfalt an welt halten und formen
wirklich als eine vielfalt von formen
während andere philosophen sehr stark
betonen wollten dass das wirklich eine
form ist die irgendwie all diese
fähigkeiten ermöglicht ich wollte dann
noch ein anderes ding sagen was für
mehrere punkte die ich heute machen
wollte wichtig ist und das ist wirklich
ein punkt was bei resellers sehr stark
gemacht wird was ich aber bei problemen
nicht so detailliert erklärt habe wie
ich möchte um das folgendes das erklären
zu können
wie gesagt ist diese grenze zwischen
vernunft wahrnehmung und ernährung so
weiter oder die grenze zwischen mensch
und tier ist sehr wichtig in der
mehrzahl sind was wir auch für designer
und unterscheidet zum beispiel das nicht
moral von dem von dem oralen es
unterscheidet das körperliche von dem
nicht körperlichen
das tierische von den menschlichen usw
aber was ich auch damals gesagt habe und
jetzt mehr betonen möchte ist dass diese
grenze die grenze zwischen um einzelne
sachen selber oder für seine sachen ist
hinsichtlich der technologie okay mein
natürlich ist meine vernunft stelle auch
eine ein einzel denn keine universelle
aber das was das internet macht das die
aufgabe das sind das internet sogar ist
universelle dinge zu begreifen
also diese unterscheidung zwischen die
zwischen den tier fähigkeiten und den
mensch und der menschlichkeit ist genau
nach seiner die unterscheidung zwischen
einer fähigkeit die sich mit einzel
dingen auseinandersetzt
wenn eine fähigkeit die sich mit
universellen mit immer besseren dingen
auseinandersetzen kann was meine ich
damit was sind universelle dinge zum
beispiel nehmen wir noch mal unser
scharf durch hat angst wie sie sehen
können
wieso hat es auf angst weil sie schon
einen wolf gesehen hat und wahrnehmen
kann dass der wolf ein seliges mit
dieser fähigkeit im es thematisch wird
und was war das das war die eine
fähigkeit eigenschaften wahrzunehmen die
zur normalen externen wahrnehmung nicht
wahrnehmbar sind zum beispiel das
feindseligkeit nichts sichtbar nicht
direkt sichtbar ist auch nicht hörbare
usw
trotzdem sehen wir dass ein schaf das
irgendwie begreifen kann was ein was ein
schaf nicht machen kann aber ist
feindseligkeit im allgemein muss er
begreifen zb denkt dass nach hey was hat
all diese wölfe gegen uns wieso sind all
die wölfe gegen alle unsere uns alle
unsere schaffen also auch gegen uns wie
sollten sie uns allen gegenüber so fein
seelig wieso haben sie haben hat wolf im
allgemeinen den schafen gegenüber
feindseligkeit das kann einen job nicht
machen ein schaf kann nur denken das ist
nicht denken altavista kann nur warnen
begreifen durch case szenario dass der
wolf das dieser hall feindselige ist
kann auch zum beispiel ein einzel sache
närrinnen zug anmerken dass der wolf der
ihnen so fein serie war gestern so viel
war auch grau war soll in der zukunft
aufpassen dass gemäss klaus in der nähe
ist vielleicht kann er kann sich daran
erinnern aber nochmal kann nicht denken
alle griffe sind gar wir im gegensatz
dazu nicht nur dafür dass wir das können
das ist dass das charakteristische
schlechthin für die menschheit dass wir
universal denken können
denn die wissenschaft und die flüsse sie
besteht genau daraus wissenschaft ist
universell denken über natur die wir in
der welt wenn zum beispiel zu begreifen
dass wir können begreifen dass das
scharfe in gefahr stellen wenn wolf in
der nähe sein weil alle wölfe einen
scharfen gegenüber feindselig sind kann
kein scharfmacher
so kann nur irgendwie merken dass dieses
denn dieses einzel denn eigentlich ist
und das war übrigens für designer sehr
wichtig weil er dadurch beweisen wollte
dass der dass das internet oder die
fanseele und körperlich ist weil er dann
gesagt hat dass die die dieses ohne
diese universelle idee oder begriff
würde auseinander genommen oder geteilt
wenn der begriff in einem körper
empfangen würde genau wie ein eine farbe
ist weiter die diese farbe weiß
hier hat man eine weiße farbe ist aber
über eine liebe das blatt papier
verteilt das heißt wir haben einen teil
von der weißen farbe und ein teil hier
und diesen voneinander getrennt und das
ist natürlich nicht was wir wollen wenn
es um das denken eines begriffes geht
wir wollen dass der begriff als
vollständige und als eine einheit
begriffen wird und das kann nur eine
körperliche fähigkeit nämlich vernunft
es ist ein beweis dafür dass das
internet keine körperlich kein
körperliches organ hat und dass er ein
interessantes argument übrigens weil das
ist
ein beispiel von einer ich habe gerade
eine aufsatz darüber geschrieben also 60
das als nebenwirkung
es gibt eine lange geschichte von
argumente design wollen dass die seele
und körperlich ist die durch die pistole
gi ein onkologisches prinzip oder ein
und logischen schluss erreicht das heißt
sie sagen sie sieht man überlegt weil
war die sind die objekte die meine seele
begreifen kann meine seele muss
irgendwie analog zu diesen objekten sein
muss ähnlich zu diesem objekten sein
der urvater davon ist natürlich wie so
oft platten im fei dann haben wir das so
genannte affinität argument wo er sagt
dass wir zwei klassen oder arten von
besen haben nämlich unsichtbar und
sichtbar und dann und die unsichtbare
sachen sind an sind ewig wurde
unzerstörbar und die sichtbare sachen
sind zeitlich begrenzt
in diesem zusammenhang feiern will er
bisher die socket easing teil dialog
beweisen dass der dass die zelle
unsterblich ist das heißt ewig existiert
und um das zu tun argumentiert so
kritisch dass die objekte unseres
wissens ewig und unzerstörbar sind und
unsichtbar sind nämlich die platonische
formen und dadurch kann er argumentieren
dass die seele auch ewig unzerstörbaren
und unsichtbar ist weil sie wenden wenn
sie nichts diese im wenn sie nicht eine
gewisse ähnlichkeit so sie denn diesen
objekten hätte können sie die zelle
diese objekte nicht begreifen und das
argument ist es ein urenkelkind dieses
argument
hier ist das argument stattdessen
universal sind um körperliche begriffe
deswegen und wenn sie körperlich
instanziert oder aufgenommen werden dann
werden sie ein einzel sachen zum
beispiel der die universelle form von
menschheit wird hier ist saniert aber
hin materie und wird ein einzel denkt
dass um das zu vermeiden muss die
vernunft diesen begriff und körperlich
begreifen und aufnehmen sonst würde zum
beispiel wenn vernunft an eine farbe rot
denken würde wäre die farbe rot verteilt
und aufgesplittet genau wie die farbe
des platz papier also es nur um zu sagen
wie wichtig diese unterscheiden ist
zwischen die zwischen den arten der
kombination wie die parteien mittelalter
philosophen sein würden also die die
aktien wahrnehmung viel gemein sind die
mit vernunft zu tun haben vernunft
begleitung universelle sache
alle andere kognitive fähigkeiten
begreifen einzelgänger und das gilt
nicht nur für es thematisch sondern auch
vorstellung emotionen natürlich sehen
man kann nichts sie können alle diese
farbe weiß sehen aber sie können nur
diese farbe weiß man andere beispiele
von dieser farbe sein sie können nicht
die farbe weiß im allgemeinen sehen
sie können auch nicht die farbe weiß das
nicht so offensichtlich aber vielleicht
trotzdem überzeugen
sie können sich die farbe weiß im
allgemeinen mit vorstellen sie können es
versuchen aber was sie vorschlagen
werden ist wahrscheinlich
und dann sieht so sind wie ich wunderbar
sie werden das eine chance was mit mir
und designer gemeinsam sei
versuchen sie sich die farbe weiß
feuchten was sie sich vorstellen werden
ist ein objekt etwas weißes oder
vielleicht ein weißes band oder sowas
aber nicht die farbe weiß um die farbe
weiß zu begreifen als universelles denn
muss man vernunft einsetzen und zum
beispiel verstehen und das ist die
zusammen das zusammenkommen aller fahren
dann haben sie verständnis der weißen
farbe sondern ein intellektuelles
begreifen davon ist aber keine
vorstellung oder gedächtnis wenn sie an
weiß apps müssen sie ein weiß erinnern
dann erinnern sie sich immer an ein
bestimmtes weiß dass sie geschehen haben
usw also all diese kognitive fähigkeiten
die bei tieren vorhanden sind haben
immer mit 1 ist eines linie zu tun nie
mit universal sobald wir bei den
universal sind sind haben wir mit einer
nur menschlichen fähigkeit und das und
das ist wirklich gut
das ist für sich gesehen weil diese
unterscheidungen zwischen universal
denken kann dann ist dann mit dieser
unterscheiden zwischen körperlichen und
körperlichen koordiniert so haben einen
körperlichen fähigkeit universelle ist
zu begreifen und viele körperliche
fähigkeiten einzel dinge zu begreifen
deswegen ist es für alle sein also
wichtig mir damals gesagt habe dass all
diese fähigkeiten konjunktive
fähigkeiten die einzel dinge sie sich
mit einzelnen beschäftigen die sind alle
körperlich bedenkt dass ist sie haben
ein jetzt ein sitz oder ein zuhause in
denen gehirn in diesem wege sind
material realisiert sie haben ein
körperliches sitz werden meine vernunft
einfach eine und körperliche
aktivität ist das genau der grund warum
ich noch denken kann nachdem ich sterbe
mein gehirn ist weg ich kann nicht mehr
vorstellen
aber meine verstandes von versetzt und
bleibt stehen zu sagen okay leider
wenn man wenn man wirklich anfängt das
zu überleben in hinblick auf das was
tiere hält wie unsere scharf wirklich
machen können
kommt man darauf dass das alles sehr
überzeugend ist mein so wie ich das
jetzt verschieben habe mag es bereits
überzeugen können weil ich weil ich ein
beispiel ausgewählt habe und dann habe
ich sein das beispiel übernommen wo
einer wo ein einzelner schaaf einen
einzelnen wolf begreift und denkt oh
herr wollten ist mir feindlich was hier
geht hat es offensichtlich mit netz
einzelne dinge zu tun weil der wolf ein
einzel sehen ist aber überlegen wir was
die feindlichkeit des wolfes ist ist der
die feindlichkeit des wolfes wirklich
einen einzel ding ist offensichtlich
kein körperliches denken und von daher
scheint es dass die dass das schaf
irgendwie durch es thema cio die
fähigkeit hat und körperliche
eigenschaften zu begreifen nein ich weiß
ich immer wieder gesagt habe das thema
ist die fähigkeit eigenschaft zu
begreifen die normal waren nicht
wahrnehmbar sein das sind nichts selber
hört sowieso nicht weil sie nicht
körperlich sind feierlichkeiten ist
nicht körperlich es ist eine haltung
oder seine neigung oder sowas ist aber
kein ist aber kein körperliches objekts
und trotzdem kann es schafft das
begreifen und hier würde aber sagen ja
das ist okay es ist zwar körperlich aber
trotzdem ein einzel denn das sind die
nur die feindseligkeit dieses wolfes und
das ist unterschiedlich von der von der
weinseligkeit eines anderen wolfes es
doch ein einzelnes okay kein problem
aber habe ist dass selbst hat gibt uns
ein beispiel wo das viel schwieriger ist
und das ist eine sehr überzeugende
beobachtung er erwähnt den hund der von
allen stücken angst hat weil er einmal
mit einem stopp geprügelt wurde
und wenn sie jetzt jemals in begegnungen
mit einer mit einem tier waren und das
heißt dass sie alle ist das klar das
tier der solche sachen machen können zum
beispiel haben wir unsere katze
trainiert dass sie dass sie wenn sie das
klingeln eines einer glocke wird dass
sie zu uns läuft bei essen jetzt fertig
ist mittlerweile kommst du sowieso genau
an die zeit aber um sie zu uns wenn wir
sie rhein locken wollen am abend können
wir diese glocke hernehmen und das
funktioniert und sie würde auch für jede
glocke kommen die genau so klingt es
liegt das können diese glocke die ein
unterschied ausmacht und genauso mit dem
grund der hund fürchtet alle starke herz
nicht also auf der hundeschau das ist
nicht der gleiche stark kein problem
der hund hat allgemein furcht vor
stocken und das
scheint zu sein dass der universell
begreift dass stücke gefährlich sind
designer hat das beispiel gegeben aber
diese diese folge daraus nichts erspart
er schloss erschossen hat erst jetzt
erst wird das problem nicht gesehen aber
es später in der islamischen tradition
gab es philosophen die gesagt haben
hey was ist mit diesem beispiel des
hundes zeigt das nicht dass der hund was
universales begreift und genauso in der
nba in der lateinischen verb übrigens
noch eine nebenbemerkung viele von den
problemen die wir jetzt in der
lateinischen mit leute sehen und viele
philosophische probleme und diskussionen
überhaupt in der lateinischen
mittelalters sind nur eine eine
praktisch eine eine zweite fassung von
diskussionen die schon in der arabischen
sprache vor 200 jahren geführt haben
würden weil sie auch unmittelbar es
würde gut unabhängig auf die gleiche
text thw seine reagieren und es gibt im
islamischen von alp islamischen osten
gibt es all die wada vor ein paar wochen
gesagt habe gibt es all diese
philosophen die auf alle seine reagieren
dann gibt es all diese floskel die auf
lateinisch dkbc reagieren und sie kommen
auch die gleichen probleme schlagen die
gleiche antwort vor und wissen nicht
dass das alles schon gemacht würde weil
sie dieses weil diese texte übersetzt du
ins sensi ich damals sagte also ich
denke wenn ich's klassische flüsse wie
aus dem lateinischen mittelalter lese
denke ich immer oh das ist die
neuentdeckung von ideen die schon in der
islamischen welt mit den mitten in
solchen jahrhundert oder
anfang des 19 jahrhunderts ion entdeckt
wurden
das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes beispiel
also all die probleme mit dieser
ästhetische theorie die in der tasche
mit leider vollkommen kommen
unabhängigen islamischen situation
vorher das erstaunlich wie ähnlich die
diskussionen sind
obwohl das alles getrennt ist auf jeden
fall
wir haben diesen dieses beispiel von dem
hund dann haben wir ein ähnliches
phänomen
und hier geht es nicht um furcht sondern
um verlangen um das war kein brauchen
wir es thematisch nichts ich glaube nur
sogar nur wahrnehmung ganz normale
wahrnehmung und zb ernährung kennt also
die neigung nahrung zu suchen
nehmen wir noch mal ein hund oder nehmen
wir ein scharfer das schaf so schön hier
aufgemacht haben ein schaf sucht futter
das ist ein schaf also das gras ist
herzlich egal welches glas das ist ein
leckeres glas gut aber es nicht also ist
es nicht als ob das das schaf genau
irgendwie diese dieser flasche diesem
fleck gras finden will will nur futter
und bei anderen tieren ähnlich alles was
ihm nach streben ist ihm was was sie
allgemein nach streben sie wollen futter
oder oder ein anderes tier mit dem es
fahren kann
aber es ist dem dem tier egal
genau welche und das scheint zu zeigen
dass sie auch universelles verlangen
zeigen dass sie suchen nach futter
suchen aber nicht nach bestimmtes futter
und suchen auch nicht nach zum beispiel
genau das futter woran sie sich erinnern
können
das wäre zwecklos war das wird schon
wieder
würde also eher psychologisch diesen
test im aktuellen und auch von der
handlung her scheint dass das leider
wissen dass tiere sehr wohl mit
universellen begriffen arbeiten können
nicht ganz wie wir aber irgendwie okay
und hier müssen wir das machen was dies
klassiker am besten machen nämlich eine
unterscheidung machen
es ist zwar der fall dass tiere
irgendwie mit begriffen arbeiten die
allgemein sind also die nicht bestimmt
sind zum beispiel butter oder gras aber
nicht ein präsident des vdr ein
bestimmtes gras nur futter aber das
heißt nicht dass sie einen universalen
begriff als solche begreifen
also ein schaf kann nichts kann nicht
über gras denken als solche kann nur
gras suchen oder gras wollen oder gras
sehen oder feindseligkeit sehen aber
nochmal das ist eigentlich der punkt den
ich schon gemacht habe
das schafft keine feindseligkeit
empfinden und kann immer wieder
feindseligkeit empfinden oder ein hund
kann empfindet dass irgendwas einen
stopp erst und reagiert genau das der
gleichen art und weise aber alle stücke
kann aber nichts ausdrücklich denken
alle stücke sind gefährlich oder alle
wölfe sind gefährlich dass sie könnten
sie bilden diese urteile mit dem wort
alle nichts und das ist was wir machen
und das ist universalist denken
universelles denken ist wenn man
ausdrücklich sagt susann satt im kopf
sagt alle sechs sind y
wir können das nicht machen wie wissen
wir dass sie das nicht machen können
weil eine stadt liest dass seine das
sagt schwierige frage wie sagen meint
vielleicht hat kann das tier das doch
machen also wenn es denn meiner meinung
nach haben die schola sechs klassen kein
keine ganz so gute antwort zu dieser
frage zu geben dass auf dass wir keine
beweise haben dass wir das machen so wie
wir das machen also es gibt keine tiere
die wissenschaft machen
also wenn sie allgemein denken können
wir das nicht beobachten
deswegen werden sind wir nicht bezwungen
zuzugeben dass sie das machen
also alles anders gesagt die handlung
und das vernehmen dass wir bei tieren
beobachten tatsächlich beobachten zwingt
uns nicht dazu
zuzugeben dass die tiere wirklich
ausdrücklich und explizit universal
denken die phänomene die wir beobachten
führen uns nur dazu sie zuzugeben dass
tiere allein allgemeines verlangen haben
zum beispiel oder kognitive fähigkeiten
haben wodurch sie allgemeine eigentlich
auf allgemeine eigenschaften richtig
reagieren können
aber wir sehen nie ein verhalten unter
den nicht menschlichen tieren was
beweist dass sie mehr als das machen was
anderes gesagt sie arbeiten generell
aber nicht universal und der unterschied
ist genau das generell ist nur sozusagen
unbestimmt also wie gesagt habe suchen
unbestimmt futter aber denken nicht an
futter als solche als eine als einen
hall gemeiner begriff dass die antwort
dass
sie geben die zulässige geben trotzdem
zu dass das manche tiere fortgeschritten
dass sind als andere tiere zum beispiel
erwähnte dass das beispiel von affen und
als sie verwenden hier manchmal das ist
das ist nicht so toll gesagt aber nehmen
sie dieses lateinische wort was auf
deutsch existiert quasi her und sagen ja
den affen können quasi denken
das heißt also ob sie denken sie ist es
soweit ist sind praktisch ganz an der
nahe an der grenze von richtiges denken
ist aber nicht wirklich denken weil du
kannst das immer dadurch erklären dass
sie mit eindrücke wie bei einzelnen
dinge arbeiten
es gibt nie wirklich ein beweis dass sie
universell denken können aber trotzdem
können sie es scheint dass sie plane
planen können es schaffen können dann
dass sie probleme lösen können oder
solche sachen
ein schönes beispiel was von ein paar
war so angeschossen wird ist der und der
sein herrchen erreichen
und der hund steht hier das herrchen
steht hier und in der mitte ist ein loch
und der hund will nicht ins loch fallen
und deswegen geht der hund um das loch
loch ich sehr beeindruckend aber da muss
man nachdenken geht wie hat er das
gemacht bei der hund also laut
klassische theorie bleibt dieser session
psychologischen theorie reagieren tiere
automatisch auf eindrücke
also man würde denken dass der hund zum
herrchen gehen will sieht herrchen und
läuft ein nein der hunde vorsichtig und
geht darum wie so
durch quasi denken also hat irgendwie
empfindet irgendwie das loch als
gefährliches und versucht gleichzeitig
zwei ziel zu erreichen nämlich nicht ins
loch zu fahren und das leicht zu
erreichen und erschließt dass der hund
um das loch dass das haben wir natürlich
vorher gesehen sogar mit einem beispiel
mit hund bei den steuern können
vielleicht erinnern sie sich daran
der hund der den weg entlang geht um ein
anderes tier zu fangen an beute zu
fangen und schnüffelt und dann kommt
eine spaltung der hund schnüffelt längst
nix in der mitte nix und dann läuft
rechts und ist offen
vielleicht wenn sie sich daran und
kritik der antike völker hat genau das
gleiche gesagt das ist fast wie sie
denken erstaunlich verstand ich dass wir
das machen können obwohl sie nicht
denken können
man sieht wie die hartnäckig sie nichts
das nicht zugeben wollten das serie
denken können also die die erklärung die
wir für uns geben würden also zum
beispiel es ist allgemein schlechten
löcher zu fallen
hier ist ein loch deswegen soll ich
nicht reingehen das kann ein tier
einfach nicht machen
es kann nicht diese möglichkeit unter
einem universalen prinzip einordnen und
deswegen muss man irgendwie sagen dass
der hund alles durch diese eindrücke von
einzelnen macht irgendwie in der lage
ist das zu machen egal wie kompliziert
das tierverhalten ist natürlich eine
große schwäche an der theorie zeigt
sogar die größte ich wollte fragen ob
jemand fragen hat aber ich wollte noch
einen dinge sagen und dann komme ich
zurück das hängt damit zusammen dass er
sich vorher gesagt habe
die diese grenze zwischen menschen und
hier gleich die seite die grenze ist
zwischen zwischen weesen die moralisch
handeln können und wesen die nicht mal
alles handeln können warum weil tiere
keine wie genau wie gerade gesagt habe
der holzmarkt hier zwar etwas
beeindruckendes also scheint zu denken
kann aber nicht richten kann mit
wirklich entscheiden
das zu tun das ist alles eine
automatische reaktion auf die umgebung
also auf das auf die gegebene situation
man könnte sagen wenn man einen hund in
dieser situation tun würde
tausendmal würde die und immer das
gleiche machen und vielleicht ist es
sogar der fall dass der hund die keine
entscheidung hat ob er links rum gehen
soll oder rechts sondern geht
automatisch in die nähe in den ähren weg
oder wenn es wirklich gleich ist dann
handelt er einfach beliebig kann aber
keine entscheidungen treffen vielleicht
kennen sie das berühmte beispiel von
johannesburg an
das ist es der vor zwei strohhaufen
steht und sich nicht zwischen den zwei
strafen entscheiden kann man stellt
einfach da das war das war dass dieses
beispiel leider kommt das nicht im bilde
davor wurde ein brillanter philosoph
also der vielleicht der brillanteste
will sollte das wir sind jahrhunderts
den mindestens in europa und es am
meisten bekannt für ein beispiel was er
gar nicht erwähnt hat das tragisch
das war ein beispiel was gegner von ihm
gegen seinen willen seine balance
erfunden haben
aber egal ob das vom papier her ist aber
nicht die idee ist dass es eben nichts
nichts essen kann nicht verlassen kann
weil die zwei strafen genau verlocken
sense wenn er kann sich nicht
entscheiden weil er keinen grund hat
keine entscheidung des grün hat aber das
beispiel das unter anderem ihrer führen
war jenny entscheidungen treffen müssen
sind der skala zwischen theorie viele
können sich nicht entscheiden sie haben
keine freie wille
sie sind automatische wesen die immer
automatisch auf die umgebung reagieren
und in dieser hinsicht sind erstaunlich
aber wahr ein schaf oder rund oder sogar
ein affe hat mehr mit vorher gemeinsam
als mit uns wenn es um handeln geht weil
denken wir an feuer indes rücken
historischen universum feuer will
so sang er zeiten will nach oben
es hat eine tendenz eine neigung nach
oben zu steigen und andere sachen zu
verbrennen
also will einige sagen verbrennen
was heißt das das heißt dass vorher
teleologische ist hat aktivitäten die
von seiner natur vorgegeben sind und
neigt dazu diese handlungen also diese
fähigkeiten einzusetzen würde sie an
aktivitäten auszuführen
zu sachen zu verbrennen oder nach oben
zu steigen
und genau so hat ein tier verschiedenen
neigungen die automatisch angesetzt
werden sobald das tier in einer
entsprechenden situation ist zum
beispiel kia hat hunger sieht futter
geht einfach hin und die diese idee
hatten wir
in der sitzung kurz vor weihnachten das
amt ihre automatisch auf lust reagieren
zum beispiel futter oder sechs sie gehen
einfach hin sobald sie empfinden dass
eine möglichkeit besteht das zu tun
wir wiederum können nachdenken denken
euro das ist doch keine gute idee weil
wir freie wille haben mindestens das
wäre die die klassische idee diese idee
übrigens kommt viel stärker in der
schola stick vor als in der islamischen
welt weil freie wille hat mit augustinus
zu tun ist kompliziert aber die das ist
dass jetzt viel viel stärker in der
teilchen welt thematisiert als in der
arabisch gleichen bett nicht dass das
hinhalten vorkommt aber in diese in
diesem zusammenhang ist es eher eine
technische idee und das ist genau der
grund warum wir moralisch handeln können
und theorie nicht du bist natürlich nur
dafür moralisch verantwortlich
was du entscheidest da wo du anders
entscheiden können hättest
und diese möglichkeit hat kein tier
es gibt keine tiere selbst die sehr
fortgeschritten in tieren die haben die
tiere sie können nichts eine möglichkeit
in erwähnung nehmen in betracht nehmen
und überlegen ob sie das machen sollen
oder nicht
und dann entweder machen aber nicht so
dass wir dann sagen können hey du hast
entschieden
das tier kann nur reagieren das ist zwar
der lage jedes tier sie haben eine frage
ja sie hat man sie kenne sogar die frage
war ob wie was ist wenn ein tier
zwischen giftigen futter und gutem
futter entscheidet sie können sogar
sachen tun die noch beeindruckender sind
zum beispiel besprechen die lateinische
so lastiger kein wo die tiere krank sind
und instinktiv pflanzen aussuchen was
die hatten das heilmittel drin haben das
wird sogar bei diskeeper welt in den
zoologischen werken ok erklärung dass
sie das schafft dass die feindseligkeit
des würfels warnen kann das tier kann
wahrnehmen dass das futter geeignet ist
also das geeignet sein ist eine
eigenschaft dieses fotos und es nicht
mehr so weder ist genauso wahrnehmbar
die feindseligkeit also die analyse darf
man es genau dasselbe uns also ich sage
ich ich würde nicht sein
jetzt würden wir sagen dass die mine
wenn wenn ein tier wirklich erfahrung
braucht um giftiges fotos sind vermeiden
dann hat es hier ein problem war dann
wenn es wirklich dürftig ist ja jemand
die idee ist dass die firma ist auch
nicht so dass wegbegleiter sich damals
bei dem scharf beispiel gesagt ist aus
nicht so als ob der scharf zuerst von
einem wolf angegriffen werden muss um zu
lernen dass der wolf ein seliger ist das
wäre ja auch schlecht an das war dem
gleichen grund ja also es muss irgendwie
instinktiv wahrnehmen dass zum beispiel
das essen geeignet ist und zb sie nicht
also das schaf zuerst an steine so heißt
es entstand aber es ist vielleicht an
vielleicht sehen wir aber trotzdem
unterscheiden es ist nicht als ob tiere
nichts lernen können
also es gibt meine sachen die sich aktiv
machen zb das richtige futter aussuchen
dann gibt es sachen die tiere lernen zb
wo er futter ist oder der rand der die
stücke fürchtet das hat er gelernt dass
nicht als auch der hund mit 54 staaten
geboren wird es ist gerade weil er
geprügelt war also die die wollen nicht
verneinen dass tiere lernen sie wollen
verneinen dass tiere universelles inhalt
lernen das ist das anders
sie können keine neue wissenschaft auf
standen sie können aber lernen oder
instinktiv wissen dass irgendeine ein
hessen giftig ist oder lecker ist ja
jaja und jemand sie können trainiert
werden ja natürlich
beides aber aber immerhin noch mal die
behauptung ist nicht dass tiere diese
ich glaube dieser einwand hat merck
gewicht gegen zb descartes als gegen
diese aristotelische lehre die wir
später sendern würde descartes sagen
dass tiere geistlose maschinen sind und
da ist wirklich schwer zu verstehen wie
sie neue informationen erwerben
ja meinten die muss ja dass er klein das
werden wir später besprechen
aber welches klassiker haben wirklich
damit kein problem das sie natürlich
geben sie das zu und sagen jaja dass es
genau wofür sie diese fähigkeiten
brauchen vorstellungen gedächtnis das
genau was du brauchst zum hit zu werden
man kann auch keine kinder trainieren
obwohl keine kinder vom jährige kennt
laut das katholische lehre keine
vernunft keine vernunft einsetzen können
das kommt später das kommt für ein
teenager also dieses zb bringen prügeln
um das lesen beizubringen hinzu in der
zukunft nichts irgendwas nichts zu
machen das ist durchaus innerhalb der
fähigkeit eines tiers nach der
ästhetischen theorie gewusst dass sie
nicht machen kann ist zum beispiel sagen
was wollen wir hier erreichen was ist
das ziel aber wir wollen das publikum
beglücken
so also so abstrakt denken kann das tier
nicht aber neues lernen kann es ja auf
jeden fall
und hier meine es gibt das pack ich
werde vielleicht was in der letzten
vorlesung hier dazu sagen
also hier passiert das nur kurz zusammen
es gibt im allgemeinen eine frage wenn
wir ein verhalten eines tippte ein
beeindruckendes verhalten bei einem tier
beobachten sollen wir gleich zum schluss
kommen dass das tier das genauso matt
wie wir es machen
oder sollen wir sagen nein ich gebe das
nur zu wenn ich keine andere wahl habe
also ist wenn ich eher konservativ
vielleicht pinkl vielleicht nicht
großzügig oder bin ich groß zu gehen
wenn ich nicht größer werden dann
versuche ich diese sehr fortgeschrittene
verwaltungs typen mit und
fortgeschrittene fähigkeiten zu erklären
zum beispiel nur gedächtnis und nicht
denken also nur automatismus nur
instinktlos
zum beispiel will man bei einer ameise
gleich sein vielleicht denken okay die
arbeiten so gut zusammen jede ameise hat
anscheinend ein hat verstand dass es
einen größeren plan hier gibt und dass
der nev so aufgebaut werden würde das
wahrscheinlich nicht aber bei einem
blind und neigt man dazu sagen okay
einfach stellt wirklich hier was los ist
aber wir glauben mehr als diese
intuition verbrauchen prinzipien für die
solche prinzipien so entscheiden welche
fähigkeiten wir den tier zu scheinen
wollen und die die frage ist ist was
diese die richtige prinzipien sense und
wie wir und das wollte ich in der
letzten sitzung beschwerden diese
allgemeine frage aber für jetzt was wir
aus dieser geschichte nehmen sollen
bleibe ich
die eine theorie ausschaut die am
wenigsten größeres wie möglich also hier
wollen wollten sie ja nie zugeben dass
tiere welt sind eine bestimmte art von
denken auszuführen
auch wenn es wirklich scheint dass sie
das machen können
natürlich haben sie vielleicht auch
nicht ganz so gut beobachtet was tiere
machen können wie wir das heutzutage
machen aber dass tiere oft
beeindruckende sachen schon tun sagen
sie selbst wirklich mehrmals gesagt habe
okay wir haben noch nicht aber noch
nicht das größte problem bereits nämlich
das zeichen der vernunft schlechthin bei
menschen und der beweis dass wir
universal decken und hier denn nichts
ist dass wir das sagen können
also habe ich habe zum beispiel gesagt
tiere machen keine wissenschaft wir
schon wieso machen tiere wie so können
wir sagen dass tiere keine wissenschaft
machen weil sie man muss das mitteilen
würden wenn sie wissenschaft hätten sie
würden das äußern ja wie wir das äußern
wir haben sprache sie nicht und sprache
ist sehr stark mit dieser idee von
universalen denken verbunden weil wir so
denken wir daran was ich gesagt habe als
ich dieses beispiel mit der farbe weiß
gesagt ja gearbeitet habe es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen die tasse hielt
dass diese dieses blatt papier weiß ist
und wenn man die farbe weiß als solche
betrachtet die habe ich sie dazu
gebracht an die farbe weiß zu denken
durch sprache gesagt die farbe weiß
nicht irgend nicht irgendein bestimmte
eine bestimmte farbe sondern die farbe
weiß im allgemeinen
das kann ich nur meine stellen sie sich
vor
ich musste das nur mit gesten machen wie
schwer das wäre da wäre das zu erklären
ich soll ich auch was soll ich deuten um
ihnen und mit sofort zu bringen dass sie
wissen ich meine die farbe weiß im
allgemeinen kann nur dieses weiß zeigen
oder dieses weiß vielleicht nach vier
fünf beispiele denken denken sie
er will die farbe weiß als solche sagen
aber ich kann das nicht so deuten
und deswegen ist was für diese ganze
historische theorie perfekt das tier
nicht sprechen
problem hier können sprechen
das ist genau das problem das wir schon
bei profillos gesehen haben und gibt und
diese diese widerlegung die er gegen die
story gemacht haben das war immer eine
gefahr für die schola stickel dass die
ja dass die aristotelische theorie sturz
durch genau diese beobachtung was macht
ein so lästig wenn solche gefahren
auftauchen des klassiker macht eine
unterscheidung das ist einmal der das
klassische lösung also der erstklassigen
muss nachdenken genau was sprache ist
und hier hat albertus magnus nochmal
eine sehr interessante theorie
er unterscheidet zwischen bloßen geburt
ihres sohnes
das sind die drei stufen sonos ist das
zum beispiel irgendein geräusch box ist
was ganz bestimmt es das ist die
fähigkeit luft durch zum beispiel
stimmbänder zu beeinflussen und die
fehlen zu lassen damit einen sohnes
gemacht wird und diese diese fähigkeit
boxes stimme diese fähigkeit stimme
haben nur tiere keine den arien pflanzen
dann kann kein box keine stimme und es
gibt einen guten grund warum sie das
nicht haben nämlich die der zweck der
stimme ist immer die objekte des
burschen der vorstellung zu äußern
zum beispiel flucht oder verlangen nach
hunger oder service also aldi aldi die
inhalte die der vorstellung zugänglich
sind kann man mit vox ausdrücken zum
beispiel wenn meine katze ohne glocke
reinkommt weil es zeit ist zu füttern
und ich glaub ich hab irgendwann gesagt
dass unsere ganze sehr gesprächig ist
die spreche aber albert des mangels
würde sagen nicht gesprächig toxic oder
stimmt stimmig die sie sie sie nutzt
ihre stimme sehr oft ein sehr gerne
manchmal sehr laut
zum beispiel wenn ich dabei bin ich
fertig vorzubereiten dann steht sie hier
und sagt verzweifelt will unbedingt
essen weil sie dieses essen schon
vorstellt
sie hat schon in ihrem kopf zu sagen
dass das essen jetzt kommt und albert
detmers würde sagen ja es ist wirklich
in ihr in ihrem kopf weil erfolgsalbums
kraft in ihrem gehirn gesetzt und sie
stellt sich
wie es sein wird um das futter zu
bekommen und wir neigen dazu dass du an
zu profitieren wenn es hat nichts zu
sagen dass die stimme dieses jahr das
lernen heißt ich will jetzt essen oder
gib mir das essen oder ich habe hunger
was auch immer nacken sagt er heute
anders
das werde strache also urteile oder
professionelles inhalt auszudrücken
dafür braucht man thermo sprache oder
rede nicht nur stimme was ist das genau
das ist wirklich interessant er sagt
dass das typische oder dass
kartellverstöße oder das was er selber
ausmacht ist dass man nicht nur luft
vibrieren lässt sondern dass man das
gliedert in verschiedene geräusche die
dann zusammengesetzt werden müssen um
wörter zu bauen damit man dann setzte
mit diesen wörtern bauen kann zum
beispiel ich will jetzt essen denken wir
dass wohl passen es gibt und ich muss
sie zusammenstellen um dieses werk zu
schaffen und dann kann ich das mit ich
und will samstag um einen satz zu bauen
und dies das sind kleine teile von luft
die ich mit meiner stimme beeinflusse um
einsatzzeit aufzubauen und der satz hat
bedeutung nur durch gebrauch konvention
also das ist auch so dass zuerst ließ
kreuzes hat ließ das fertig sagt auch
dass das würde keine natürliche
bedeutung haben
es gibt ausnahmen wie den oder spaß aber
im allgemeinen haben wörtern nur
bedeutung dadurch
dass wir zugestimmt haben die wird dass
diese geräusche so schwer zu nehmen und
das kann im tiere nicht nochmal einwand
doch es gibt papageien die das machen
nein noch mal dass cola sticker albert
landesklasse sein dass es die wollen
nicht mit dieser mit diesen wörtern
bedeuten sie nahmen nur die geräusche
nach machen können sie haben box sie
können hören sie können einen box ein 1
1 mit dem wort wieder geben also eher
kannst du kein papagei können sie
trainiert werden um es zu sagen
time out to be oder ich will es sogar
kann saniert werden das zu sagen wenn
der dieb avantgarde trotzdem würde es
nicht heißen dass der dass die papagei
spricht war dass nur wir machen können
weil nur wir diese diese inhalt
konzipieren können und dann sprach er
signalisieren können was in papagei
faltern passieren würde ist dass der
vögel sozusagen automatisch dieses
geräusch mit futter zusammenbringt oder
assoziiert und kann das geräusch äußern
wenn es futter will weil geräusche
nachahmen und väter wollen kann es
machen es kann verschiedene sachen
einzusammeln bringen das macht es aber
es kann nie denken ich will jetzt erst
dann das sagen und das zu verlangen
übrigens sie haben sogar zugegeben das
tier immer dass papageien manchmal in
der lage waren neue sprachliche haus zog
erst zu verwenden die sie nie gelernt
haben zu kombinieren zum beispiel einmal
erwähnt
mein papagei sagt avi kaiser und sagte
das habe ich selber ausgedacht
ja aber trotzdem okay vielleicht
dasselbe nicht also alles nur nach
langer ist nicht wirklich
es geht ein bisschen zurück zu ihrem
einwand man sieht wie die un- bereit
zuzugeben dass tiere das menschliche die
menschliche fähigkeit haben
es soll in diesem fall es gibt ein
institut einen interessanten grenzfall
nämlich jetzt wird es etwas aller
während des alarms am albertus magnus
und andere so laciga das ist der
berühmte das berühmte beispiel albert es
hat einen teil seiner theologie woher
die dieses volk gesperrt wovon er
reportagen gehört hat nämlich so kleine
leute die irgendwo im süden können
und er sagt also nach den berichten die
er gehört hat ist er unter dem eindruck
dass diese prämien nicht ganz menschlich
sind
er weiß aber dass sie sprechen können
und deswegen sagt er ja okay das ist die
die pikmin sind anscheinend die
nichtmenschliche tiere die am weitesten
gekommen sind so dass sie fast menschen
sind und sie können sogar sprechen sind
aber ein grenzfall weil ihr sprechen
immer mit einzel sachen zu tun hat sie
haben keine wissenschaft weil sie nur
wörter hernehmen um einzelne dinge zu
erwähnen und können nie die die
abstrakte idee erwähnen oder darauf
hätten mit strache hinweisen
natürlich müsse man jetzt hier
nachdenken
wie würde diese sprache funktionieren
also mein mann kann sie keine schwache
vorstellen wo jedes substantive einnahme
ist also sozusagen verschiedene wörter
für jeden stuhl haben müssen und für
genau wie wir das für jeden schaden und
für jedes jede stein würde einen namen
haben müssen so kann es nicht sein dass
sie müssen ein wort wie stein haben was
für alle steine umsetzbar ist
vielleicht denkt albertus dass der das
pigment genau wie tiere so reagieren wie
papageien oder was immer er sieht stein
und sagt stein
aber kann system ansteigen ich denke es
ist sehr unüberlegt und natürlich wäre
besser gewesen wenn er natürlich
natürlich besser als mehr um können wäre
es besser gewesen wenn er einfach
zugegeben hätte das picknick menschen
sind aber das wollte er nichts ich
glaube das hat ihn auch interessiert
also diese und ich würde sagen ich meine
dieses beispiel ist natürlich nicht sehr
attraktiv wie gesagt aus mehreren
gründen habe es irgendwie philosophisch
gut dass er nichts dass er nicht
vermeiden wollte diese grenzfälle fälle
betrafen er hat ausdrücklich dieses
beispiel überlegt und besprochen weil
das ein grenzfall waren das hat ihn
interessiert habe das sein wird eine
prompte stelle bei albertus magnus dann
in den ersten fünf minuten wollte ich
nur kurz eine an ein anderes thema
erwähnen einfach weil es immer wieder
vorkommt wenn man mit letztlich für das
vieh und ihre denkt das hat nicht so
viel mit unseren zwei hauptthemen
nämlich tätig und tier zu psychologie zu
tun
ich wollte es aber trotzdem gesagt haben
dass es eines ortes und dann vor allem
mittelalter diese theorie gab dass tiere
spontan generiert werden können
zb verlautete fleisch können firma in
flieden entstehen und die frage es gab
eine frage im mittelalter die in der
islamischen bleibt schon diskutiert
würde in der lateinischen wird auch wie
das zustande kommt weil es kompliziert
kann passiert aber im allgemeinen grob
gesagt es ist der fall dass tiere
dadurch entstehen dass die form des
vaters in die materie im gebärmutter
vorhanden ist irgendwie eingepflanzt
wird
und dann entsteht ein tier dallas das
ist die allgemeine theorie glaube ich
habe das irgendwann hätten sich alles
gesprochen habe und hier haben wird ihr
die einfache sozusagen aus heiterem
himmel entstehen ohne vater und auch
meine mutter
wie kann das sein und auch könnte man
sich fragen welche arten von tiere
spontan entstehen können wie senna der
der meinung war dass alle tier alle
formen alles substanzielle formen von
einem universellen internet strom und
von materie empfangen wird wenn die
materie gut vorbereitet ist hat hat
behauptet dass sogar menschen spontan
entstehen könnten wenn die materie genau
richtig ist aber einfach sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich com nie vor
aber fliegen und würmer weil sie so
einfach sind können leiht entstehen weil
man braucht nur ein bisschen materie die
ein die so richtig ist ein bisschen warm
sonne
verf altes fleisch for service hat
dagegen behauptet nein das ist nichts
einfluss eines internets das ist ein
fluss von himmlischer bewegung
das heißt die materie wird körperlich
präpariert und einfach ohne vor entsteht
ein neues tier
erstaunlich ist die energie also keine
tiere und wenn die vorm anwesen ist
vorher denn nur potenziell es gibt nur
die potenziale der materie selbst alle
tiere zu werden und die noch mal diese
diese taten sind so einfach dass nur die
materie reicht so lange die materie gut
vorbereitet ist und weil das von unten
kommt von oben sagt alvarez das nur sehr
einfache arten von tieren spontan
generiert werden können
und dann gibt es das man man staunt zu
sehen wie umstritten das in den latein
mittelalter war also alles kann haste
körper hass haben was dazu zu sagen
haben alle ihre verschiedene meinungen
und eine hauptfrage ist eben ob mann ob
das ein rein körperliches verfahren ist
oder ob wir irgend eine spirituelle
ursache darin gott ein intellekts oder
sowas zum beispiel albertus magnus der
thomas wirken ist der ansicht dass es
recht hatte und dass man das durch
heimliches einfluss erkennen kann aber
spätere soma sticker sagen nein gott
muss die form dann pflanzen usw
es gibt auch interessante interessanten
fragen dazu wie menschen entstehen und
ob diese untere cent ein anderes
verursacht werden heißt diese oberen
teile zum beispiel will albertus magnus
sagen dass die unsere fähigkeiten rein
körperlich entstehen durch samen und
blut in der normalen atem
aber und entstehen in den in dem
entwickelnden baby in dem gewerbe in der
gebärmutter aber die rationelle seele
muss direkt von gott kommen und hier ist
übrigens interessant zu beobachten das
albertus und dann ist ein schüler thomas
von aquin wollen beide sagen dass die
fanszene erst mittendrin also nach ein
paar monaten entsteht nicht am anfang
also die hat werner kuhn der haupt für
das oft der katholischen kirche würde
sagen dass gerade entstandene
entwickelnde babys keine menschen sind
interessante weise des verblüffend die
sind natürlich und arbeit natürlich
potenzielle menschen was vielleicht
moralisch entscheiden ist vielleicht
nicht das ließe sich vorstellen könne
jetzt das auch selber städten in der
station der literatur aus
offensichtlichen gründen aber das ist
das wollte ich nur erwähnen damit sie
dass das auch verschiedene theorien gibt
ersten zur frage wie die tiere und
menschen normal entstehen
das war einst zur frage ob tiere spontan
entstehen
diese theorie dass tiere spontan
entstehen würde erst in 18 60
beantwortet von louis pasteur hat ein
experimente geführt die bewiesen haben
dass die das tier dann nicht spontan
entstehen können dadurch dass er dass er
gefahr tisch fleiß in glas und ohne glas
in der luft stehen lassen hat und die
würmer und fliegen sind nur ohne glas
bekommen und das hat bewiesen dass
irgendwas aus der umgebung gekommen ist
okay das war es für heute nächste woche
erreichen wir die instanzen fallen
werden wir italienische renaissance